für mord und totschlag in der fiktion
wir haben nach antworten gefahndet
wir sind süchtig süchtig nach dem
verbrechen
wir lieben geschichten in denen gemordet
und gestorben wird
warum ich mir am liebsten alte gemälde
von kreuzigungen mord oder krieg
anschauen weil sie trost spenden
verabredung im keller mit johannes b
er erforscht das unheimliche in der
kultur und sagt dass er vorne böse macht
das reale böse erträglicher klima durch
film das unheimlichste moment bevor
beruf gut sie wissen noch nicht was im
moment was oft taucht der moment als
monstrum gesät ich zwar ein schock aber
gleichzeitig abraten beruhige ich will
was mich angesehen
das kann man irgendwie den verstorbenen
bekannten
der chor oder die angst und schrecken
sorgen hätte so ein kilo statt einem
schlecker essig komplexer vielleicht ist
es gerade form zum ein angst vorm
schreckliche angst vor der cloud zu
bannen indem man sie aber ganz genau wo
es um in norddeutschland rentnerparadies
und krimi hochburg im beschaulichen
örtchen hess der verband der
deutschsprachigen krimiautoren seine
flagge die örtliche wellness oase wird
zum tatort der krimi bewegung
fachgespräch über mord und moral ergänzt
mit leichtem fitnesstraining mit dabei
christine brand die berner
schriftstellerin hat eben ihre vierte
mordgeschichte veröffentlicht die
magischen fantasien der 300 autorinnen
und autoren machen durstig
apéro schwarz über leichenstarre
ermittlungsmethoden und den perfekten
ort wo man erwischt wird dabei
natürlich einer der nicht aufgeklärt
wird
aus sicht des täters aus sicht des
lesers
den würde ich auch begehen stiller hass
der neue kriminalroman von christine
brand darin ermittelt eine journalistin
im schweizer polit million zustößt auf
kinderpornografie und mehrere leichen
dies ist über einen spaten geschwungen
in holzschemel liegt umgekippt am boden
der rechtsmedizinerin genügt ein blick
auf maxi folge komme zungen und seine
blau verfärbten hände und zu erkennen
dass er nicht mehr am leben ist
mord ist mehr als ihr hobby es ist ihr
lebenselixier christine brandt wuchs im
elterlichen bestattungsunternehmen auf
der tod ein selbstverständlicher teil
des familienlebens eine szene
rechtsmedizin was ich mir als mail
geschrieben nicht mein kind wird groß
geschrieben in jedem krimi bricht das
entsetzliche in die idylle rein und
genau das lieben wir so sehr denn hier
gilt wo eine leiche ist gibt es auch
eine lösung krieg tendenziellen
kriminalroman antwort sinnvolles
kongress der alle details der detektive
einer wand in ordnung bringt neue ideen
sind das etwa eingeworben hat wo sinn
hat wo man nun muss könne lasse wie
schreibe ich eine schöne vorstellung
vielleicht ist realität aber nicht so
nicht realität nützen
die sucht nach düsteren
kriminalgeschichten spiegelt die
sehnsucht nach einer heilen welt glänzt
unser alltag mehr als nach dem
auftauchen aus dem düsteren krimi kosmos
wenn sie krimis mögen dann werden sie
diese woche unserer verlosung lieben